welcome to the pretty intense podcast on
the show today is scientist and
Professor Ben bickman he's actually a
metabolic scientist he studies insulin
in particular is his one of his areas of
expertise but fat cells he's got a lab
that he's feeding and growing fat cells
and all kinds of crazy stuff he also is
an author he has a book called why we
get sick which is hugely popular doesn't
everyone want to know that knowledge is
power guys we started off with just kind
of the simple question that I feel like
arises within so many of us which is why
do I get fat and how do I get skinny I
feel like it's a very linear
comprehensive conversation about a topic
that can be a little complicated for
sure things like you know what is that
fat coffee doing with butter and MCT oil
in the morning what role is that playing
in ketones what's actually happening are
fat cells locked in on the amount that
we have do they grow and Shrink or do
they go up and down in the count I mean
all of these questions get asked
um and so I I think this is an insanely
valuable episode to understanding how
the body works and how to maximize it
for the most efficient fat burning and
to essentially lead to not only a longer
life but your best looking body in the
meantime so I hope you enjoy it please
hit subscribe if you like this please
let us know in the comments your
thoughts and maybe some tips and tricks
what's been working for you but in the
meantime enjoy this episode and this
deep dive with Ben bickman on really
insulin we definitely don't have enough
time to today I have so many questions
as I always do when it comes to help but
I thought I would start with sort of
like the simplest maybe maybe simplest
sort of Baseline and also maybe one of
the biggest Curiosities is just
why do we get fat and why and how do we
get skinny yeah and by skinny I mean
healthy I don't know I get it okay great
we're just we're looking at both ends of
the spectrum here yeah yeah how do we
get rid of the fat we don't want yep
yeah yeah so it's I wish it were as easy
as most people claim which is purely you
know everyone so
um emphatically and enthusiastically
invokes the laws of thermodynamics you
know that's this whole idea of calories
in calories out thus you need nothing
more than to put yourself into a caloric
deficit by eating less exercising more
and now fat cells will start to shrink
and not to make a tangent already but I
mean there's a lot of reasons to want
the fat cells to shrink
um my work really highlights much of the
problem that comes from fat cells being
too fat if you will and all the
metabolic and pro-inflammatory
consequences of that so beyond wanting
to you know look good and where the
clothes we want and have the clothes fit
on us the way we want it to there are
you know real you know even even more
consequential reasons so the prevailing
Paradigm is that we just need our fat
cells to shrink through cutting calories
either putting Less in or putting more
out you know that's kind of how we
balance the laws of thermodynamics and
calories matter there's no question the
amount of energy coming in compared to
the amount of energy going out is
vitally important but that
prevailing Paradigm of just get into a
caloric deficit
starts to have multiple it elicits
multiple mechanisms to start working
against it because we don't want to
start to starve we don't want to be in a
caloric deficit the body senses this as
a little bit of a panic and part of the
evidence although this is a little
anecdotal but for for showing how this
can be problematic is look at what
happens on people who are on the The
Biggest Loser TV show you know everyone
knows that show and boy talk about
extreme caloric restriction where they
are on you know practically starvation
diets and they are exercising hours a
day and there's no question
they lose weight but that that strategy
starts pitting them against their own
hunger and so you know case in point
imagine if I were inviting everyone over
to a buffet and it is an all you can eat
and it's the best chefs in the world
making the most delicious foods and I
invite everyone come and come hungry
you're going to want to enjoy all this
what would people do to make sure they
came to this Buffet as hungry as
possible they would eat less in some
time preceding this delicious dinner and
they would exercise more so that they
could come as hungry as possible to this
event and yet that's the exact advice
we've been stating for decades on how
people should lose weight but it make
yes it will work in the short term but
it starts working they have to now
battle their own hunger more and more
and more and in this environment of
readily available food hunger will
usually win which is why in the case of
this this game show with with these
people who lose a phenomenal amount of
weight you never see them on a reunion
tour or something similar because hunger
comes back and rears its ugly head so to
put all of this in just a perspective to
put a nice fine point on it
yes calories matter and I think it
should be leveraged it should be some
step in a weight loss journey to help
shrink the size of the fat cell not the
number of fat cells that is a different
matter entirely but it shrinks the size
of the fat cell Yes Energy must somehow
be accounted for or reduced but
shouldn't be the first step this fat
shrinking Journey should start by
addressing hormones first in my view
because obesity or or fat cell
manipulation is really a matter of two
two variables the caloric variable which
is the only one most people look at and
then the endocrine or hormone variable
we know that animals will store or
expend energy based very heavily almost
exclusively on the way on the the
hormone levels and there are many
hormones that play into this including
adrenaline something you know a race car
driver would know a lot about hormones
like cortisol you know the most famous
stress hormone both of those are
actually
stress hormones but also
I overworked those yeah yeah yeah that's
right and you're doing fine so you've
made it work really well but um sex
hormones you know uh progesterone will
have a different effect from estradiol
from testosterone but then kind of
sitting on top of all of these
is the hormone insulin it isn't it isn't
um too bold of me to say it is
impossible in a human body for a fat
cell to shrink if if insulin is elevated
insulin is a hormone that will promote
energy storage it wants to that's kind
of the Thematic effect of insulin from
top to bottom it will promote energy
storage uh an interesting example of
just how profound this is is looking at
someone who has Type 1 diabetes of
course in type 1 diabetes a person isn't
making any insulin and if they are under
dosing insulin or aren't on insulin yet
they will be eating thousands of
calories a day thousands and yet they
are wasting away Getting Thinner and
thinner and thinner because they can't
there is no potential to store energy on
that body because there's no insulin to
tell the body how to store the energy so
it's basically what insulin is doing
that in fact this will be the perfect
example across the hallway from my
office here is my laboratory the
metabolism lab on my campus we grow fat
cells we are literally growing fat cells
in little Petri dishes right now in the
lab and we will have these fat cells
swimming in a little bath of of calories
there will be glucose in this there will
be fatty acids in this culture medium in
this bath and yet the fat cells will
stay small and skinny if you will and
it's not until we start putting insulin
into the bath of these cells that they
now know what to do with the energy
that's all around them
cells don't know what to do with energy
unless they're told and it's hormones
many hormones insulin is Paramount that
tells the cells what to do with energy
now some people have heard me say this
and say well Ben's trying to deny
thermodynamics not at all my PhD is
bioenergetics I have an acute
appreciation for energy in cells and
organisms but a cell must be told what
to do with the energy that it has and
Insulin does that so to answer your
question after this long-winded
explanation the first step in my mind
should be altering the foods you eat in
such a way that you don't have to go
hungry you are nourished you're eating
when you want to eat but you are
lowering your insulin by lowering
insulin you will start you will
accelerate your metabolic rate we've
published papers on that others have for
decades we know that happens low insulin
increases metabolic rate so you're
expending energy better and you will
start burning fat much higher because
when insulin comes down fat burning will
turn on at a much higher rate and so now
you are learning to use your own fat for
fuel you're you know that's what fat
cells are it's like we're walking around
with these energy bars strapped onto our
bodies now we're finally opening them
and using them but only when insulin is
low so the first step don't work against
hunger just eat what you when you need
to eat but focus on foods that will help
your insulin come down which is
basically in fact I know you've had
people on the podcast previously that
have touched on this in more detail but
it's my rules are control carbohydrates
to help your insulin come down don't get
your carbohydrates from a bag or a box
with a barcode whole fruits and
vegetables Dynamite but then the next
two rules are absolute musts because
while you are controlling and generally
eating fewer carbohydrates you don't
want to be hungry all the time so focus
on protein and fat which will have very
minimal if any impact on your insulin so
that's the first step help lower your
insulin and then once you've gotten to a
plateau
if those fat cells aren't quite as small
as you want them to be now you take the
next step which is now I'm going to
start controlling energy coming in and
that is best in my view when done simply
through the lens of intermittent fasting
and there are many many ways to do that
but start with the low insulin step then
the lower calorie approach
that was a very cohesive clear and
articulate well done
um okay one question real quick
I feel like maybe this is a could be a
myth but
can we get rid of fat cells or can we
only shrink them and grow them yeah well
I'm thrilled you're asking this yeah so
in the average person and there are
exceptions to this but but the
overwhelming majority of people will
fall into how I'm just going to explain
it we will start making new and more and
more fat cells throughout infancy
childhood and and Adolescence puberty
then when we come out of puberty the
number of fat cells we have is typically
set
so this is going to be late teens in a
girl and then you know roughly 20 maybe
even early 20s and some guys you know if
a guy
yeah well so so it's flat line that was
a joke yeah I know yeah so it's
flatlined until from around 20 until we
get to about 60 to 65. okay and then it
starts to come down which is interesting
but that doesn't mean fat mass is coming
down this is fat cell number and so we
would look at this kind of drop and say
oh well then we should be getting lean
as we get old but depending on how the
person is living what they're eating and
how active they are
um what that means is the remaining fat
cells went from this big to this big
because they now have to carry a larger
part of the the metabolic burden because
there are fewer of them around and that
is when problems start and paradoxically
fat Mass itself isn't the best indicator
of how metabolically sound a person is
going to be are they going to have
pre-diabetes or hypertension or
infertility or early stage Alzheimer's
all of those are very related to
metabolic Health but but it's really how
you're storing your fat if you have
fewer cells but they're all really
hypertrophied a hypertrophic fat cell
that is very pathogenic it's very
pro-inflammatory there's secreting
pro-inflammatory proteins and they
become very insulin resistant which
starts to spread insulin resistance
throughout the body or on the other hand
you have people a small sliver of people
who can just keep making more and more
fat cells and they all stay kind of nice
and small and happy and metabolically
healthy but they just have a lot more of
them well it's not the number of the fat
cells that's problematic it is the size
and this has been borne out through
Decades of incredibly well done studies
around the world a lot of the pioneering
work was in Scandinavia we've had a lot
of wonderful scientists here in the U.S
that have confirmed these findings again
and again over the years so it's not fat
cell number
it's fat cell size and that's what as I
noted that's where most people that's
how most people get fat
um where where they they get to
adulthood they stop growing the number
of fat cells then any further fat growth
on the body is the hypertrophy of the
remaining fat cells and so you'd ask do
we ever lose them fat cells have a
lifespan of about 10 years and so in the
average person every 10 years a fat cell
dies but up until the age of you know 60
65 it'll just get replaced by a new fat
cell and then it's at that age you know
in the 60s where as the fat cells start
to die off they don't get replaced in a
kind of one-to-one ratio got it okay so
that theory is not a theory or that uh
that is not a myth that is true
um all right let's get back to insulin I
know this is like very much an area of
your expertise and your research
um so
I get a little confused okay so I
believe to that this topic is
challenging to comprehend to some degree
because
the metrics seem opposite like you want
to be insulin sensitive which sounds bad
but it's actually really good so like
there's a little counterintuitiveness to
it so maybe try and sort of run through
the basics of how it works how insulin
works and the role it plays and then I'm
gonna hammer down on some questions and
Curiosities around it oh yeah yes
absolutely
um so insulin resistance is my kind of
One Singular
um research Focus among among several
that we have always going on in the lab
but that is the one thing I focus on the
most to understand insulin resistance
and why we use that term to describe the
problem and it is a problem Danica I
mean as much as we want to say oh well
everything in the U.S we're so fat and
lazy and we're the worst not at all I've
given talks about insulin resistance
literally around the world and when it
comes to the top 10 countries with the
most people with pre-diabetes or insulin
resistance per capita we're not even in
the top top 10. so this is a global
problem now what is insulin resistance I
think it's best described as imagining
it as a coin
so I'm holding this coin called insulin
resistance and it has two sides on one
side is the phenomenon of insulin
resistance explicitly which is that the
hormone insulin isn't working properly
at all cells of the body
now I state it that way carefully
because while some cells aren't
responding very well to insulin some
cells are responding perfectly well but
globally we call that insulin resistance
so insulin isn't working normally that
might be the best way to explain the
insulin resistance side of the coin but
then we flip the coin over and it is
always on the other side you don't have
one without the other in this case the
other side of this is hyperinsulinemia
which is just a clever way of saying
that blood insulin levels are elevated
now to understand there's a kind of a
perfect example of this to understand
how insulin resistance
both sides of this the two aspects of it
is so problematic we can look at the
examples of
infertility and in women the most common
form of infertility is a condition
called polycystic ovary syndrome PCOS
in men the most common form of
infertility is erectile dysfunction now
but each of them represents one of the
side of the coins in the female with
PCOS that is the problem of the
hyperinsulinemia but she has insulin
resistance because they always come
together these two sides of the coin but
in her it's not the insulin resistance
per se that's the problem but her
chronically elevated insulin that always
is with insulin resistance and when
insulin is elevated one of its not only
does it tell cells what to do with
energy but it also controls the
production of sex hormones insulin has
its hand in everything and it's a little
known fact
that all estrogens were once
testosterone and then the ovaries or the
testes in the women or and or men and
men respectively it will take the
testosterone and convert it into the
estrogens through an enzyme called
aromatase now ovaries naturally do it
much higher than than testes do which is
why women have relatively much higher
estrogen levels than men do but insulin
will inhibit that enzyme and so if
insulin is high now her ovaries are
taking all this testosterone hoping to
convert it into this much estrogen but
it doesn't happen because insulin is
slowing down the reaction so she ends up
with too few estrogens to go through a
normal ovulatory cycle and too many
androgens or too much testosterone
giving her perhaps some acne or some
coarser body hair which is all a result
of the higher testosterone now again
that was in the woman which was the
problem of the hyperinsulinemia side of
the coin of resistance but in men
it is the insulin resistance part of it
where one of insulin's additional
effects is to help blood vessels know
when to dilate or expand to improve
blood flow wherever it may be of course
in the case of erectile dysfunction
that's obvious but when the blood
vessels become resistant to insulin's
vasodilatory effects when the blood
vessel should dilate it stays
constricted and thus erectile
dysfunction is a result so in some
insulin resistance is a problem because
it's not working the right way and we
have too much but with insulin
sensitivity then insulin does its job
well and it is also at a very low level
so if insulin is needed it comes up it
gets the job done and it goes back and
it goes you know starts resting again
until it's needed again
got it okay and what is insulin
responding to oh yeah yeah wonderful
yeah so insulin's most famous effect is
to control blood glucose that is its
most famous effect so if there's any
obvious response like in other words
what's the trigger for insulin despite
the most obvious and impactful would be
anytime we eat something that's very
starchy and sugary then we will get an
insulin Spike and depending on
how much we've eaten and what else it's
coming with it can come up and come down
very quickly or it can come up and it
may take three or four hours for it to
come down and that is what becomes a
problem in our well I would say our
culture but it's the global culture it
truly is where we wake up in the morning
insulin has come down overnight
um because insulin is the hormone of the
FED State we've been fasting overnight
and so it's come down we spike it up
with a starchy sugary breakfast or a
sugary coffee or some juice and then
damn that Kellogg's for making cereal
yes something oh my God yeah yeah yes so
I mean it's the deck is stacked against
us where does uh where breakfast is
basically just a dessert in most homes
and and so it's take it takes two or
three hours for it to start to come down
and by then we're getting a little
hungry and we have a mid-morning snack
of more starches and sugars and sugary
drinks and then it does again for lunch
and throughout the rest of the day and
so we're spending every waking moment
and even well into the night with this
elevated insulin and that right there
I'm answering a different question now
is the leading Pusher or leading um
variable promoting insulin resistance
there are other inputs that cause
insulin resistance absolutely and I've
studied almost all of them directly
myself and published papers on them but
I'm convinced that the one that is the
most impactful is the chronically
elevated insulin and all you need to do
in a human is just start giving them
some insulin and they'll start becoming
resistant to it as it gets too high
within just hours so too much insulin is
a cause of insulin resistance I love
Health in this like wellness and I love
testing things I have a CGM on right now
um and it's so interesting to also watch
it with women's hormones but okay so
something happens so let's just talk
about food first food you eat something
um blood sugar Rises which then creates
an insulin response it comes in catches
it brings it down
if it does that in a short amount of
time and if you wear a continuous blood
glucose monitor and you watch this on a
graph and it spikes and comes right back
down is that a bad thing no no it's not
um it is the frequent spiking of the
glucose if the person were doing that
um you know so it will ideally in a
healthy person of course depending on
how much they eat but let's say they had
a couple pieces of bread just as an
example that that glucose ideally it
would come up and be back down to normal
within a a two hour window yep the
longer that starts to push out the more
reflective it is of an underlying
problem now wouldn't it be amazing if we
had a continuous insulin monitor boy
that would to superimpose these and
you'd know make it oh my gosh believe me
there are labs around the world trying
to do this there's incredibly technical
hurdles that prevent it from just being
done but someday we'll get there but but
the glucose curve itself can be a little
misleading because you know you are a
lean insulin sensitive person you eat
those two pieces of bread your glucose
started to come up you had a nice big
rush of insulin and then the glue pushed
the glucose down and you were down in
two hours it's possible that someone
who's less metabolically sound would
have a similar similar looking glucose
curve but the insulin curve could have
been three or four times higher than
yours was that is the insulin resistance
so the glucose curve is incredibly
helpful okay so we're not seeing insulin
we're just seeing glucose that's what we
don't know is the level of insulin
response yep that's exactly right you
can't know that unless you are taking
some blood and getting your insulin
measured which of course is technically
very difficult okay so then what happens
when let's put another scenario out
there so
I go work out this morning I do like a
little I do a little more of like a hit
training where I really like really get
out of breath in intervals for about
25-30 minutes
I looked at my blood sugar oh my God
yeah that [ __ ] Spike to like 140. I was
like that's pretty high for a workout
yeah does ins is insulin's roll even
when there's not food involved no no I
love boy you're tuck we are getting
really into the meat of all this so
earlier we talked about the stress
hormones exercise is a stress so when
you started really hitting it hard there
was there there so there are two
important things if I'm thinking far
enough ahead of what I'm about to say
the first one is that during exercise
insulin is antithetical to exercise
because insulin wants to feed everything
in the body including fat cells for
example so let's look at these two
opposing cells fat cells and muscle
cells naturally when we're exercising
the muscle wants everything it's a very
demanding tissue if insulin were
elevated it would be feeding both of
them equally and the muscle cell would
say justifiably that's not fair I'm the
one who needs it all my my metabolic
rate has gone up 50 times compared to
what I was was moments ago whereas the
fat cells doing nothing like it usually
does that's not entirely fair but
metabolically speaking not doing
anything okay so the muscle cell has a
back door
whereas normally muscle is only able to
pull in glucose as a fuel if insulin is
there to knock on the doors of the
muscle cell and open the glucose doors
in fact really that's the most most of
where when when someone's watching their
glucose curve come up and down once it
starts to go down 80 percent of what's
pushing it down is by the glucose coming
into the muscle and insulin's opening
opening those doors except for when we
exercise when we exercise the muscle is
so hungry that it basically says I can't
wait for insulin insulin is going to try
to feed everybody so I'm just going to
start taking it in myself so there's an
insulin independent mechanism the moment
the muscle starts exercising it opens
those doors on its own and so so the
glucose starts coming into it and
Insulin stays very very low during
exercise insulin comes down very very
quickly but the glucose levels start to
climb so this is the second part of
what's Happening which is because of the
stress hormones cortisol and
particularly adrenaline or epinephrine
as it's called these hormones and and
some other ones growth hormone and and
uh
glucagon there are a lot of these
hormones that will respond the moment
the muscles start exercising and start
pulling in the glucose the glucose
levels start to drop in the blood these
hormones sense this through the brain
and through some other mechanisms and
they start to say okay muscle is hungry
let's make sure the muscle gets fed and
so these stress hormones will start to
come up and they will tell the liver
which is like the ultimate Giver you
know it's like the soccer mom it's doing
everything for the rest of the family
and the liver where is the lover yes
yeah in fact in Persian cultures a term
of endearment we say oh you're my
sweetheart but in certain older Persian
cultures they would say they would say
you're my golden liver
it's like they knew that the liver yeah
the heart is a one-trick pony it's
important but it only does one thing the
liver does like it is at the Nexus of
all nutrients whether it's lactates or
ketones or amino acids glucose or fatty
acids the liver handles it all and the
liver gets this message saying oh hey
the muscle needs something well the
stress hormones like adrenaline will
come to the liver and tell the liver to
start making a whole bunch of glucose
and that is what pushes the glucose up
during a stressful event even if
nothing's coming in glucose starts to go
up because it's the liver that starts
pushing it into the blood all with the
intention
of feeding the very hungry muscle during
exercise that mean that it's a fatty
liver then no no well if you were to uh
do you in the case of exercise creating
the glucose release No the liver can be
perfectly lean and not essentially have
a speck of fat in it
so does this blood sugar Spike matter is
it an indicator or a marker of anything
how high your blood sugar spikes in
response to the hormetic stress of
working out yeah yeah well said uh no it
doesn't nope generally what that's just
going to be a reflection of is how
perceived how hard the stress is on the
body basically how hard are you
exercising which is why if you just go
on a walk I mean you could go on a walk
that was say two hours in length and
expend the same number of calories as
you did in a 30 minute hit workout so
you know all things equal the the
absolute amount of you know power that
went into it maybe we would say was
equal and yet the glucose curve would
have been nothing on a walk it would
barely would have moved because the
intensity is just so minimal that as the
muscles are moving the blood glucose
pressure to go down is so minimal that
there's only a modest production of
glucose from the liver but when it is
just sort of all out the liver just
overshoes shoots and just flushes the
blood just wanting the with I guess with
the perspective that it's better to over
feed the muscle than it is to underfeed
it got it so which one is
better for you well yeah people could
answer that differently I'm very much an
advocate of intensity I think intensity
trumps duration every time
good
yeah uh okay
what about ketones what about
what about the role of that and you know
my understanding is the brain either
feeds on sugar or it feeds on ketones
and ketones are produced when blood
sugar is low I guess that would
inevitably mean insulin is
low
um and I mean I even you know playing
around with this you know Mindy pells
you've spoken to her before uh she's
we're working together on a bunch of
various different things biologically
and
um so ketones is a marker I'm using and
it's in it's it's crazy how again women
woman's cycle is so very interesting but
also when I have a coffee in the morning
and I put some MCT oil in it and some
butter or some cream some basically fat
I mean I can make my ketones go up for
sure with that more than I would
otherwise so explain to me ketones and
what ketones do and if ketones
themselves play a role in fat reduction
yeah yeah wonderful yes so ketones are
simply pieces of burning fat
for lack of a better description so now
let me explain it generally
um there uh at the whole level at the
whole body there are multiple fuels that
can fuel the cells of the body
um now it varies a little bit depending
on the cell type but in general a cell
can burn fat it can burn glucose it can
burn ketones it can burn lactate lactate
is a fuel that's never talked about but
all of these are are fuels they're kind
of the only fuels really
um but when the body so but at the whole
body level the the overwhelming majority
of fuel is coming from fats or sugars
you're sugar burning or your fat burning
in some ratio at any moment and insulin
I hate to seem like I'm overstating it
but insulin absolutely dictates which
fuel is being used uh I mean
authoritatively in a dictator it
determines which fuel is being used if
insulin is elevated the body is sugar
burning and I mean absolutely I mean you
can you can induce this shift in just
minutes in a human by infusing some
insulin in contrast if insulin's down
the body shifts and it goes to fat
burning
now if insulin is down for a prolonged
period of time
then then the body burns fat to meet its
energetic needs and then basically even
though it's met it's need you know this
is how much energy the body needed
insulin fat burning went right to there
but because insulin is staying so low it
can't stop fat burning and so we start
burning more fat than the cell actually
needs for its Fuel and if that excess
fat burning if you will is what gets
shunted into this ketogenic pathway and
starts making ketones now that is how we
make ketones in in the kind of whole
body just from nutrition but you
mentioned MCTS once again a ketone is
simply a piece of burning fat and MCT
the shorter the fat gets you know most
fats we eat are long chain fats we store
them very well we can burn them too but
the shorter the fat gets like a medium
chain fat or a short chain fat like the
short chain fats that you get from
vinegar which it is a short chain fad
those cannot be stored
they can only be burned there's no
option to store them I'm just reading
the MCT oil burning yeah so yes so when
you put an MCT and you see your ketones
start to boost that's now that you're
burning more of the fat that you've just
put in the tank you know you're just
kind of burning that superficial you're
not getting into your own stuff not real
well well I'm not saying it's good or
bad because it depends on what the goal
is but if the goal is I want to get some
ketones to feed my brain I would say
thumbs up that's a great way to do it
because as you noted the brain is itself
a hybrid like the whole body primarily
relies on fats and glucose with some
additional fuels sprinkled in but the
brain is its own hybrid relying on sugar
or Ketone it doesn't burn fat it uses to
build itself but my lab just published a
paper a few months ago we're about to
publish another one the part of the
problem with the yeah so we we have some
human tissue and some rodent tissue um
rodent studies that we've done but even
in the human studies where we had access
to brain samples from people post-mortem
from tissue donors that it's the glucose
burning pathway in the brain that is
obliterated when it comes to cognitive
decline or Alzheimer's disease
these are brains of people who just stop
they forget how to burn sugar and so
they become increased but they don't
forget how to burn Ketone they are
perfectly capable of burning ketones for
fuel but the average individual is
living a life of so chronically elevated
insulin that they never start making
ketones so someone putting some MCT in
their coffee to boost their ketones I'm
all over that I think it's perfect it's
good for neurodegenerative diseases
absolutely but if the goal is I really
want to burn my own fat well then I
wouldn't I still wouldn't say well
that's bad thumbs down but I would say
well now you're burning that fat and
once you've burned through that now
you'll get back to burning your own fat
I see what about so would that be that
would be the same then for exogenous
ketones too if you were taking them
ketones just go directly right it's kind
of like the direct Nitro line that is
that immediate fuel you don't have to
kind of reproduce it through a back door
so what would make it difficult for
someone to be able to activate that fat
burning mechanism and burn their own
ketones yeah yeah so well yeah firstly
it would be activate the fat burning to
make their own ketones and then it would
be you know burning the ketones next but
that would be I mean the easiest example
of what would prevent that would be
someone who has chronically elevated
insulin or in other words they're
insulin resistant if you have two people
who
everything was equal on them although it
couldn't be but one was insulin
sensitive who in other words living a
life of a low-fasted insulin State and
the other was insulin resistant in whom
insulin is always a chronically elevated
and they immediately they ate a meal and
they started fasting the insulin
sensitive person will have much higher
ketones much sooner you know their
ketones will start to go up in just
maybe 12 hours but in the insulin
resistant person they may need 18 to 24
before you're starting to see that
Needle start to move so if you have like
a ketogenic diet and you or a low sugar
low carbohydrate diet should you be able
to essentially stay in a state of
ketosis through the whole thing what a
wonderful question it is I consider a
ketogenic diet to be a nutrient fast now
let me I'll explain that briefly if if
we were to say let's get into ketosis as
quickly as possible where the well the
absolute fastest way is just to stop
eating if you are fasted truly no
calories coming in insulin has to start
to come down whether it's quick in an
insulin sensitive person or a little
slower in an insulin resistant person
regardless it immediately starts to come
down
quickly or slowly because insulin is the
hormone of the FED state it is
antithetical to the fasted state so that
is a that is what I call a caloric fast
but of course you have to eat at some
point the caloric fast has to end some
energy has to come in well if the if the
point is
to burn as much fat and to stain ketosis
maybe you want to stay in ketosis
because it helps prevent your migraine
headaches which it does very very well
or you do it because you want to
maintain you know better cognition which
it also does well or any other number of
reasons then I would say the best thing
to do when you end your caloric fast is
to move into this kind of nutrient fast
other fasting starvation scientists in
the past would talk about insulin like I
just did which is saying that insulin is
the hormone of the FED State and anytime
insulin is low that would be a fasted
State whether it's a true fasted state
in the caloric fast or whether it's a
pseudo-fasted state is in the case of
what I call a nutrient fast which is how
you described it you simply control the
foods that are spiking insulin the most
and if the food's coming in even though
there may be an abundance of calories
have little or no effect on insulin like
protein and fat well then the body
continues to behave in a way as if it
were fasting insulin stays High other
hormones like glucagon stay low and and
the autophagy is very activated which is
kind of a prototypical sign of fasting
um and and the body continues to behave
biochemically as if it were fasted even
though there are in fact calories coming
in
a good idea to reduce fat and to
keep insulin Low by keeping blood sugar
low but not make a fast uncomfortable
and
reduce cognitive function would be to
take exogenous ketones MCT oil or fat in
some sort of liquid form that you could
then be using those to some degree but
then essentially keeping yourself also
in a caloric deficit
because you're basically using them to
like bridge the gap in Comfort
yes yes that would be a perfectly
suitable strategy
um and I will I just want to add as much
as I am an advocate of fasting and I am
uh the benefits are Myriad from from the
kind of Soul or the mind of a person to
the body I think fasting is incredibly
helpful and I'm an advocate of it
however
I'm also an advocate of eating smart
independently of when you're eating or
the fasting and so I believe more
important than how long a person fasts
is how they end their fast and that I
think is sometimes overlooked where a
person will be gloating about their 24
or 40 48 hour fast and yet at the end of
it they binge and just go Bonkers on a
bunch of junk food and so in a way I'm a
little afraid
that in some instances fasting has
become a kind of glamorous binge Purge
cycle which is a callous way of saying
it I know but but the person's fasting
fasting fasting they get really hungry
and they kind of break and they just eat
a bunch of junk and they know they
shouldn't be doing it but they keep
doing it and they get over full and
they're stuffed and they're
uncomfortable and they have some shame
and they say okay I'm gonna do better
tomorrow and they end up doing the same
thing again so I would say rather than
you know trying to just grit through a
long fast and getting uncomfortable and
hungry and breaking
maybe do shorter fasts for at first and
learn the discipline that comes from
planning out how you will end your fast
and sticking to the plan and and so
you'll say Okay I want to end my fast
and this is what I want to eat I'm going
to give myself a little time so that I
allow myself to feel full which I will
more easily because I've been fasting
and the stomach is a little smaller but
that takes a lot of planning and a lot
of kind of mental fortitude but again
how you end the fast is more important
than how long you go got it I want to
ask you how the best way to end a fast
but first before that
um maybe you could just share what
Pathways or mechanisms are not being
maximized in the practice of a fast if
you are consuming
um fats or exogenous ketones
um what what are what are we what would
I be missing if I did it that way yeah
well the only thing I can think of would
be that you are you would have all the
benefits of low insulin which is
significant because if you're just
consuming pure fat you will not be
spiking insulin so autophagy which is
the process of keeping a cell young if
you will autophagy will be activated
um fat burning will still be turned on
um the body will be insulin sensitive
allowing blood pressure to be better
allowing fertility processes in men and
women to be better the liver to be
leaner Etc so all of that would continue
unabated the only
difference would be the only kind of
tangent to this would be that for that
moment you are now burning the fat that
you just put in
and so so you burning your own fat to
make your ketones would have been paused
a little bit or not paused it would have
been slowed down because now you put
something in place that got in front of
it you know if there's like this
metabolic cue of nutrients waiting to
board the metabolic bus you know fat
burning is boarding it's boarding it's
boarding and then you start you put some
fat in the system it immediately takes
priority boarding especially if it's MCT
which can only be burned it can't be
stored so it goes right to the front of
the cube priority boarding and
everything all the other fat passengers
have to wait in order to get on
so if you're in an overall deep caloric
deficit let's say you consume 500
calories a day and exogenous ketones I
don't even know if exogenes I've never
taken them before but I have them now
um you could you could yeah you could do
that so it'd just be you just you'd be
in a calorie deficit just you just
wouldn't be as as much in a calorie
deficit you wouldn't be using as much of
your fat for fuel but if you could do
that more often it might be a win
overall yeah I think kind of
incorporating those strategies where
okay I'm going to fast but then for this
little window I'm going to drink in
these ketones or this MCT that might be
something that helps promote satiety and
helps you get through another six hours
yeah in that case I'm absolutely an
advocate about it but an important thing
about ketones though and this is one of
the reasons why I didn't want to get
into this at my first
um the first topic you brought up which
is how to shrink fat cells basically
because I feared it would be too much
but now you've brought us into ketones
anyway but the the very unique aspect
and it is totally unique among all
nutrients is that ketones represent a
kind of break in the caloric model or
the the caloric view the thermodynamic
view of obesity because the strict kind
of straw man view of this is that it's
just calories in calories out energy has
to be consumed or burned but when it
comes to ketones we've introduced a
third option
which is wasting because every time
you're breathing out ketones or you are
urinating out ketones which the body can
do if ketones start to climb we start to
literally eject these from the body to
some modest degree every Ketone that
comes out represents about four calories
that would have otherwise had to be
burned through exercise or or stored and
you know kept in the body as in fat or
in stored glucose molecules so ketones
represent a wasting and this is another
way where I think we we get it wrong and
we just focus on calories because if
we're focusing on insulin first insulin
is down not only is metabolic rate up
where literally the engine is literally
idling at a higher RPM just an idle but
then we have this extra additional
exhaust valve called this emission of
ketones where we are now losing you know
potentially hundreds of calories in the
form of ketones being breathed out or
urinated out so ketones are totally
unique they have a value roughly
comparable to glucose and yet unlike any
of the others there's a way to just get
them out of the body and so it's so we
don't so as much as people will deride
adding some fat into your coffee saying
oh and I kind of was almost it might
have sounded like I was well don't do
that because then you can't burn your
own fat
well a lot of that is just not you're
not going to store it anyway you're just
going to breathe it out so you have
calories now it's not going to be a net
negative or even net equal you certainly
would have retained more energy than
you'll emit from this but but it's not
like it is it's not like it's a
one-to-one where okay every calorie
coming in has to be stored or burned
through exercise now we've introduced
this wasting mechanism that again is
totally unique to ketones well we have
this fun system that rules so many lives
of a nutritional label with calories on
it and what you're saying is that
whatever the process is of putting a
number on a bottle of MCT oil or a bar
of fat or whatever it is is that it's
not in fact accurate in certain States
yes from a thermodynamic standpoint 100
you said it perfectly this is why I rail
against the thermodynamic view or the
caloric view of obesity so much not
because I'm trying to say calories don't
matter but if you were to drink 100
calories of pure Ketone or eat 100
calories of ice cream in the ice cream
with the insulin Spike as a part of this
because of the sugars in it those
calories must be accounted for either
through storage or through burning you
exercise a little more for example but a
hundred calories of Ketone you can't
store that it is just going to be burned
and in some instances it's just going to
be wasted through the body through this
new exhaust valve that is unique to
ketones so it I mean if there were a way
and you couldn't do this because it
would depend on the person's insulin
levels but if there were a way to know
okay the functional calories and the
foods that I'm about to eat the
functional calories so a hundred
calories of a ketone functionally
speaking it's probably only like 50
calories you know it it cannot be you
can't fully account for it because you
can't account for what ketones are going
to do just by way of getting breathed
out or urinated out or what ketones are
going to do to increase the metabolic
rate of fat cells which is something my
lab is published in humans in in rodents
we know that ketones will increase the
metabolic rate of fat cells where the
100 calories from the ice cream isn't
going to do any of those things it's
every calorie has to be accounted for so
100 calories of ice cream is a hundred
calories but a hundred calories of
ketones functionally speaking is maybe
only 50 or 60 calories
are there any discoveries in your lab or
in your work that up regulate fat
um disposal
um and shrinking of cells other than
fasting yeah oh for sure in fact I even
just alluded to some of the most
compelling data we've now published
three papers on this which is that when
ketones get elevated in in an organism
it will well a human um you know the
peak of all organisms then when ketones
are up the metabolic rate in fat cells
will climb to about three times higher
than normal
yeah so we did this in humans we had
humans come into the lab in a normal
non-ketotic State and we pulled a biopsy
of fat from their belly then we took
that little piece of kind of whitish
yellowish fat back to the lab across the
hallway and measured the metabolic rate
in those fat cells and then following a
period of time in ketosis we had them
come back in and we pulled another
biopsy and sure enough the metabolic
rate in men and women in those fat cells
was two to three times higher across the
board closer to three than two and so
even here we have this in the caloric
theory of obesity and you know
thermodynamics cannot account for these
kinds of things but hormones can because
ketones are only Up Normally
traditionally when insulin is low and so
this insulin is just so determined to
store energy that it will suppress every
mechanism that would waste energy in
contrast when insulin is low it's a
free-for-all
all of the cells all Energy starts
mobilizing and the body just gets into a
higher kind of catabolic or a higher
burning State now this isn't I don't
want anyone to think that I'm declaring
war on insulin it is absolutely an
essential hormone you have to have it it
is death in short order without it but
we live in this culture in this moment
in time where most people have far too
much the average individual's insulin
levels are about in the U.S about two to
three times higher than what I think
they should be and the problem gets even
worse in the Middle East and in in in
Indian in the Indian continent as well
among Indian nations uh it's it's much
higher even than we have
um I recently interviewed Paul saladino
and um he said that really one the most
important longevity marker is your
fasting insulin level
yep um I've been saying for years what
are your
um and then you went on to say if your
doctor doesn't want to give you that do
that test for you should get a new
doctor like hell yeah if a doctor
doesn't want to do a test that a patient
wants then they should always be fired
in my opinion
um but what
um what do you recommend for that uh the
frequency of that test
and what levels do you believe are the
recommended healthiest fasting insulin
marker yeah yeah so I think I think an
annual insulin test is is great
um now I am an enormous advocate of
measuring insulin focusing on it as a
marker and to the point that I I wrote a
book and anyone who's listening go by my
book why we get sick all about insulin
resistance and I really outline one of
several blood tests and I'll mention a
couple now but fasting insulin is a
great one and to me fasting insulin
should be six micro units per ml or less
that's in the kind of conventional US
units anywhere else in the world who
measures insulin and Pica moles you want
it to be in the high 20s you know no
more than 30 picamoles it that's kind of
strict and most clinicians would hear
that number and and just gefa at it
because they would say well first of all
there is no consensus insulin is so
overlooked as a hormone that we've never
spent the resources to find out what
should be like the strict marker for it
now my my
um
laying it out that it should be six Mark
you're in its micro units per mil I'm
not making that up it is based on very
good amount of evidence
um based on you know traditional
hunter-gatherer cultures and on the
statistics we know in the U.S but the
average American is up into the teens
they're fasting insulins around 13 and
it gets even higher in certain other
areas around the world like I mentioned
so you know it's about double what it
ought to be but the problem with insulin
as much as I'm beating the drum of
measuring insulin and keeping it around
six micro units per mil or less
insulin like every hormone has a
circadian rhythm to it there's an up and
a down there is an ebb and a flow to it
and it's possible that someone listening
to this went for their annual checkup
demanded that the physician which you
sometimes have to measures insulin and
reluctantly The Physician does and the
insulin comes back at say nine or ten
well that is higher it's meaningfully
higher it does it does carry a greater
risk of type 2 diabetes but what if it's
possible we caught it at the peak in
this circadian rhythm which varies
somewhat across people that in reality
it would have been around five or even
four that's a little bit of a jump but
let's just say it well then all the more
reason to look at some other tests like
the triglyceride to glucose index which
which is anyone can look this up or
Google it might go get my book or the
Homa index or the triglyceride to HDL
ratio which should be around 1.5
although it moves a bit across the
different ethnicities but there are
these other kind of lipid or fat based
tests of the blood that if someone can't
convince their physician to measure
insulin that's okay you will always get
your lipid panel which will include your
triglycerides and your HDL cholesterol
and you will always get glucose and just
with those three markers you can do two
of the metrics I just mentioned and by
all means look them up or look at the
book The triglyceride to glucose index
you want it less than five or the
triglyceride to HDL ratio and you want
that less than 1.5 those are very good
signs that you're doing okay if it's
below those ranges there's one other
test I just have to mention because it's
if you're friends with Mindy then you
know Mindy kind of eats this kind of
stuff up the sex differences with with
metabolism and isn't Mindy a character I
just I just love her she's so passionate
yeah oh she's she gets fired up I love
it so there's one other test called the
adipose insulin resistance index or the
adipo IR
and this is a fascinating example of
nutrient metabolism and the relevance of
hormones earlier I said that insulin if
insulin is elevated it shifts the body
to glucose burning and we see this in
part in the blood because when insulin
is up free fatty acids which is a blood
which is a blood test you can get free
fatty acids will be down and that's
because free fatty acids come from the
fat cell when the fat cell is breaking
down fat through a process called
lipolysis it'll break down the stored
fat which is triglyceride and release it
into the blood as free fatty acids so
all free fatty acids come from fat from
lipolysis from the fat cell well insulin
abhor is breaking down fat so if insulin
is High free fatty acids will be low
insulin inhibits lipolysis but when
insulin is down lipolysis is activated
and now free fatty acids go up a lot
but this is where the sex differences
come in really where if someone has
insulin resistant fat cells which is
where I believe insulin resistance
starts then they will have this
paradoxical scenario where insulin is
elevated but it's not able to fully stop
the fat breaking down in the fat cell
now that doesn't mean a fat cell starts
to shrink because insulin keeps pushing
fat into the fat cell or helping it come
in but now it can't stop it from going
out so the fat cell gets stuck at a
certain size it reaches a point of
growth and then stops there basically so
Fat's coming in but now fat is coming
out in the form of free fatty acids so
if you have high insulin and High free
fatty acids that means you have insulin
resistance at the fat cell the very
first stages of it now the sex
differences are what's very compelling
in this test whereas the previous test I
mentioned can apply across men and women
equally in women though women at any
moment have fat cells that are breaking
down fat at a the rate of about 5 fifty
percent more than in men so lipolysis at
the fat cells in females is 50 percent
higher than any fat cells in man at any
given moment and so a woman will have a
free fatty acid level that is higher you
know 50 even to a hundred percent higher
than a man's free fatty acids because
she's just constantly burn breaking down
fat her lipolytic rate largely because
of estrogens is at any moment
significant 50 percent higher or so than
what it is in a man and so now you have
to look at two different metrics
so whereas in a guy an adipose IR index
which accounts for the insulin and the
free fatty acids he is healthiest if his
level of that score the adipo IR score
is less than five because women
naturally have free a higher free fatty
acid levels because she's naturally more
lipolytic or fat burning than a man is
her her adipo IR index is closer to
around seven for it to be considered
healthy it's naturally higher so we have
to use a different test for men and
women to account for the different kind
of fuel metabolism across the Sexes hmm
so that sounds like women should be
getting much skinnier ah yes it does but
that only accounts for what's coming out
of the fat cell because progesterone
wants to be putting more fat in to the
fact yes
it ends up oh and progesterone
stimulates hunger it's absolutely a
hunger hormone a very real variable in
the nor in an ovulatory cycle that most
women might not know why they're feeling
the way they are and of course I can't
suppose to know what that's like I get
sometimes accused of talking about
things I shouldn't I know Endocrinology
very well
um man or woman but nevertheless
progesterone does stimulate hunger but
it also stimulates fat cell growth it
wants fat cells to grow so anyway that's
why women aren't naturally leaner
they'll naturally be a little have more
fat than men by Design because of the
sex hormones
um and and even that has a deeper
underlying reason I hate to get on a
tangent but women bear the metabolic
burden of childbearing and so having
more fat on her body is a metabolic
insurance that if I'm going to get
pregnant I need to know I have enough
energy or I should say her body should
need to know that it has enough energy
to carry the baby full term but even
once the baby's born traditionally of
course her metabolic work isn't done
because now she's going to start oozing
her fat into her breast milk to help
that little baby stay as chubby as
possible so women literally need more
fat to be fertile and that's and that's
reflected in the fact that you cannot
have puberty happen unless the fat
derived hormone leptin is elevated
there's no puberty without leptin and
there is no leptin without fat cells and
women make more leptin in her in their
fat cells than men do and in general
just need more of it than men do and
that's kind of her body's way it's her
brain's way of saying do we have enough
fat to carry a baby and the leptin will
be the signal that tells the brain in
fact puberty starts with leptin if you
take out the leptin there's no puberty
no development
um in any in any body
um and so people who have leptin
mutations won't go through puberty
unless you give them leptin it's that
essential to to development but again
women just have a greater metabolic
burden you know by Design right and so
she has to have more fat the body's
literally designed for it but she turns
over her fat more than a guy does
whereas guys fat cells just kind of sit
a little more static leaking a little
more slowly but inputting a little more
slowly in a woman's it's coming through
Fat's coming in but Fat's coming out
we're workers but that explains why
amenorrhea is uh you know you lose your
cycle because you don't have enough fat
to carry a baby so your body goes peace
wind on that yep we're not ready the fat
means not enough leptin and not enough
leptin means that the brain shuts all of
puberty and fertility down
so we've talked a lot about obviously
uh insulin
um sort of blood sugar and its
relationship with food
um ketones
metabolic rates increasing with that so
I want to get to
really the role of of the macronutrients
and because
the only thing that doesn't raise blood
sugar which inevitably then activates
your insulin response is fat
so
pretty sure you I don't know if you can
live off of just fat
so when would you share what the reason
is for consuming protein which people
don't you know don't realize that
protein does make your blood sugar rise
not to the degree that carbohydrates do
but it does
um and then also then the role of
carbohydrates I mean we can distill that
down a little further we can get into
micronutrients or fiber or things like
that but maybe just sticking with the
three major macronutrients oh yeah yeah
for sure good yeah so um yeah so there
are
um when we look at macronutrients among
the many ways we could view them and
we've been talking about them so far in
uh in the perspective or in the context
of what they do to insulin and glucose
but there are other aspects to
identifying or defining the
macronutrients and you touched on it
which is the essential aspect of it and
with fat
um you could live
you could live longer probably eating
pure fat than any other single
macronutrient you would live longer
eating nothing but fat ice for a two
second story I was walking the dog and a
neighbor was like yeah you were talking
about fat in these things and like blood
sugar and whatever and you said you had
like a hundred grams of fat that day I'd
be like heart attack and I was like not
really like like it just depends on what
kind of fat and you know what else
you're eating anyway that was the
response that a normal human would get
it's like oh my God 100 grams of fat
that's a heart attack yeah that's right
oh yeah well you got a coronary weight I
mean it's just reflective of how
powerful the message has been for so
many decades on how on how harmful fat
is I mean we absolutely have a fat
phobic culture and one of the hopes of
my career is to play some part in
dispelling that myth and helping people
not fear fat I'm an enormous advocate of
fat especially from animal sources and
fruit sources when the fat that comes
from the Flesh of a fruit which we the
humans we've been eating for well since
time immemorial that's you know coconuts
avocados olives where you just get the
Flesh of the fruit and you press it and
now you have an oil
um as opposed of course to the seed oils
which I know you've discussed previously
um which are which are harmful in any
number of ways and do in fact cause
insulin resistance at fat cells so
they're problematic even in my immediate
domain of research
um but yeah so I think it's safe to say
although there's some speculation in my
answer if we were to pick a person would
live longer eating nothing but pure fat
but
um for multiple reasons
um including that the energy would allow
the muscles to stay intact and so your
need for amino acids would be diminished
massively but that is I hate to get on a
tangent but I promise I'll come right
back that's the difference between
fasting and starvation the difference
between fasting and starvation is how
much fat do you have the moment you run
out of fat it stops being a fast and now
it's starvation because now you're
cutting muscle in order to survive ah
that this is why you can have a morbidly
obese Scotsman as happened decades ago
under clinical supervision fast for over
380 days
it's because he had so many hundreds of
or millions of calories of energy stored
on and he literally didn't eat his thing
and conventional thinking would say well
he's he's going to start wasting away
and his muscles are going to go away no
because the fat was providing all the
fuel the body needed and so the muscle
was preserved but the moment we run out
of fat now it's starvation starvation
occurs when you run out of fat and you
start cutting muscle so that's why I say
yeah that's why I say you could probably
live longer on nothing but pure fat
um and then eventually you'd start to
become deficient in the essential amino
acids which is why some degree of
protein is considered essential because
there are such thing as essential fatty
acids although we have a lot stored in
our own fat cells so if you're breaking
down your fat you're releasing those
essential fatty acids including some
omega-3 fats to properly nourish the
brain but nevertheless there are such
thing as essential fats there is there
are such things as essential amino acids
making fat and protein the two parts the
two macronutrients that are in fact
essential to live a full life
now carbohydrates I don't mean to sound
dramatic in this and I don't mean for
someone to take that I am advocating a
zero carbohydrate diet I'm not but the
fact is a person could live and live
well with not eating any carbohydrates
there is no such thing as an essential
carbohydrate and again I'm not declaring
war on it at all on that class of
macronutrients I think it can be part of
a perfectly well done healthy diet but
it doesn't change the fact that there is
no such thing as an essential
carbohydrate even the most even the most
dogmatic dietitian would have to
reluctantly admit that that is true
there's just nothing essential to them
again it can be part of a healthy and
good diet but you don't need them and so
my view on nutrition is
the sum of all of this is that I would
rather Focus my diet on two things well
for two reasons focusing on protein and
fat one they will happen to have the
least effect on my insulin which I
consider to be healthy and smart for
living a long healthy life and two they
will give me what I essentially need in
my diet to ensure I'm not becoming
deficient and then the fact that
carbohydrates happen to be both the
biggest insulin Spike Spiker although of
course it depends massively on the type
of carbohydrate but also not giving me
anything that I utterly need that is
essential well then I'm going to have
that be the smaller part of my plate if
you will and I'm going to focus most of
my caloric attention on the fat and the
protein
so carbohydrates are just for enjoyment
that I think is a good way of saying it
yeah I would be open to someone trying
to prove that statement wrong but it
would have to be a considerable argument
because the evidence is quite clear that
they are not essential right well I mean
at least yes that I that seems clear
um
I know like working with Mindy there is
a list of certain
um more carbohydrate
driven foods that are good for helping
with progesterone
and so to keep a woman's cycle going as
long as possible you want to feed
with those nutrients to give
progesterone's best chance of building
to keep your cycle and
um delay yeah I don't know that's
probably true yeah what about
um
well we need to have the conversation
about vegetables it's so prevalent in my
life right now like you know of course
Paul you know he
maybe not venomently but he doesn't eat
his vegetables there's lots of those
kinds of people and and that are talking
about you know oxalates and sort of the
chemical the the chemical fighting
um markers it has to remain a plant on a
bush so it doesn't die so lectins of
course are such a popular one that so
many especially gundry have made popular
um or well known about so what is the
role of vegetables then
yeah so go ahead just be divisive it's
totally fine well opinions yeah well
it's not generally my nature to want to
be too polarizing so I will I will start
by just validating I love that you have
an opinion you you listening to you I do
great because you you are happy but I
also get the impression from you that no
matter what you're okay to change your
opinion if the science or if the oh yeah
data tells you something different and
so I think as human beings as we go
along in life we I have lots of things
that I believe in tell you what I didn't
believe in them back you know a year ago
or five years ago and that changes for
every aspect of my life so we have to we
have to kind of practice something so
right now what is that practice and
awareness yeah yeah well thanks that's a
nice way of saying it yeah I mean I am
I'm a scientist which means I'm a seeker
of Truth and I'm constantly trying to
prove theories false unlike
some scientists these days where it's
become you know almost a religious sort
of fervor
um but never I mean the nature of a
scientist is to prove things wrong I
feel like that's totally your guys's
domain you come up with a theory you you
test it out the math the science works
and then EV there is like almost it
seems I don't know how many multiples of
effort but there's so many multiples of
effort that go into disproving it you
guys like are a culture of like trying
to vet things out wrong it's bad well
we're supposed to be I'm I I don't know
that we are as much as we used to uh and
there's a very interesting well that's a
tangent that touches on kind of cultural
issues here but I mean there's
definitely a trend for that where
science is um kind of turning into a bit
of a religious fervor now I don't say
that to denigrate religion I'm myself
very religious
um but uh but I but to me these are
different things and and I think that
to in too many instances nowadays
um when when there is an a kind of
ardent
um zealous proclamation of you know I
believe the science or I believe in
science I think belief should have
nothing to do with it
it is it is this cold analytical process
of what are the newest data and does it
does it refute or how does it challenge
the hypothesis that I was operating
under before that and people have not
wanted to continue to do that they've
had some evidence that they believe
shows their theory is valid and then
they're done that might be why they say
I believe the science is because they
say I believe what I found is what's
true no you cannot say that as a
scientist or if you want to be
kind of thinking like a scientist does
or what I should just say is any
rational person but nevertheless
um to the question about vegetables
I will validate the the concerns that
some people have expressed
um there are indeed such things known as
anti-nutrients in in plants that will to
some degree or another try to blunt well
try to discourage the animal from eating
them humans included by by among other
possibilities preventing the digestion
or the absorption of whatever nutrients
are in the plant now in our wisdom and
capacity we have bred plants in such a
way that very often these anti-nutrients
are little I mean very I mean I don't
know that you could get rid of them
completely but they would be so minimal
as to not truly disrupt the absorption
of the you know the minerals the
vitamins or some of the nutrients well
the nutrients would only really be the
macronutrients would only be glucose
there are such things as anti-nutrients
I believe people unwittingly expose
themselves to higher levels of it when
they eat concentrated sources of
vegetable matter like pea protein or
soybean protein if it's not fermented we
know that those anti-nutrients can get
enriched in those protein sources
ironically making it so you can't even
digest The Limited amino acids you think
you're getting
so which is why I'm vehemently opposed
to plant protein as a supplement because
plants are so deficient in protein in
general that you have to take say a
thousand peas and concentrate them to
get the amino acid
um serving size that you want but while
you're concentrating your mind yeah well
that's it's because what we've it's
unnatural mankind humans are not meant
to get proteins from Plants because
plants don't have protein yeah you would
be protein deficient which is why you
get a thousand peas distill them for
their amino acids but in the process of
concentrating and concentrating you end
up concentrating anti-nutrients and
heavy metals which is why lead an
arsenic can be elevated in plant
proteins yeah these These are in a way
it's common sense and this has all been
validated there's third party entities
that have tested the amount of heavy
metals in protein supplements and plant
proteins just steal it by a mile
um they are the big offenders now I
don't mean for this to say
that no one should ever be a vegan
knowledge is power though but I can't
apologize if it sounds like I'm saying
that because humans are not meant to be
vegan and veganism is a privilege of the
elite where you have to be educated
enough to know what your deficiencies
will be because you will have
deficiencies there's no questioning that
and you have to be wealthy enough to
afford the high quality supplements to
make up for it so if you can do that all
right well then all right high five
you're gonna be fine hopefully but you
have to meet those two things and so
don't be telling other people to do it
if they don't have the knowledge and
they don't have the means to afford the
supplements to make up for it so it's
two parts but
coming back to the idea of the
anti-nutrients they are genuine real
things the heavy metals that get
enriched when you concentrate the plants
although that wouldn't be a concern in
just eating an apple but that still
doesn't change the fact that there's
nothing utterly essential to them now
there might be something I've been
stewing over in my head what you said
about Mindy and the thought about
measuring progesterone there's a part of
me that would think all right I mean
insofar as progesterone is a hormone
that of course is essential to gestation
and pregnancy that's pro-gestation you
can't get pregnant without progesterone
you can't carry that little baby oh you
wouldn't really ovulate in the first
place normally without it or have a
normal ovulatory cycle progesterone is
among its many effects it wants fat
cells to grow
um but but it can't do that without
insulin's help and so maybe there is
something to be said for getting a
little modest insulin Spike from time to
time and that enabling progesterone to
do what it needs to do among many things
which is want fat cells to grow or want
to store more fat which is one of
progesterone's effects independent of
ovulation it is a it is a fat storage
hormone so maybe there's something to be
said for it but by and large there's
nothing you know kind of
quintessentially important or rather
essential
um to the carbohydrate so my view is
they they are this is a food well plants
vegetables to be more precise because
that's how you brought this question up
I think vegetables are things that can
be enjoyed and and maybe even used
deliberately with a purpose for to a
healthy end
um and that's why I'm very warm to
vegetables eaten not not don't drink
them of course don't juice them
um but but in general I would still say
the bulk of what's coming in should be
protein and fat yeah is there any uh
final thought on the vegetables is there
anything that you can't get from the fat
and protein
um from vitamins minerals micronutrients
standpoint that you would need a
vegetable for
well we're pushing the limits of what I
know because I'm not a dietitian you
know I'm a nutrient kind of biochemist
but
it would be I can't readily think of one
like for example people would say well
you got to get a banana for potassium
well you can get plenty of potassium
from other things they would say well
you got to get leafy greens for vitamin
K well you'll get much better vitamin K
from cheese or any kind of fermented
dairy they would say you got to get
calcium from this well you'll get
calcium from you know Dairy of course or
what's a vitamin C
vitamin C you'll you will get scurvy and
so you have to eat um citrus fruits well
um the the funny thing there is you use
vitamin C to make collagen that's it's
that's what the C stands for and so if
you're already eating a lot of collagen
because you're eating meat well then you
make less collagen and you don't need a
lot of vitamin C so the little teeny bit
you get from meat is more than enough
yeah
um but yeah fiber fiber is not essential
there's no question about that it's just
essential if people have a particular
affection for stool habits you know for
bowel movement habits you know but but
you don't need it you will still have
bowel movements on a purely carnivore
diet they will just be smaller and less
frequent and you will have no gas I mean
there's no flatulence on a carnivore
diet at all
wins and losses yeah so that's why every
wife wants her husband to be on a
carnivore diet amen okay before we let's
like that's I think this is enough
information
meltdown mode maybe for for some for for
me and digesting all of it so maybe just
kind of I I'd love to hear at this point
in time in life and with all of the
research that you've done
um just kind of maybe to share what what
your most important practices and
beliefs are right now for your health oh
yeah yeah what a great question
um I so I am I'm a Family Guy um husband
and father first and foremost as much as
I go on a podcast and you know write a
book or whatever that all touches on
what I've learned in my training but you
know what who is me my core is absolute
husband and father so I very much think
about the lessons I learn in the home
and in the workplace and one kind of
Mantra or or idea that keeps me grounded
and enjoying life is to take my duties
seriously but not myself
if that makes sense and so while I
appreciate the duties and obligations
that I have as a husband father as a
professor as a scientist as as a you
know part of my my congregation in my
neighborhood at church I take all that
very seriously but I don't take myself
seriously and I don't take others
particularly seriously which allows me
to laugh at my mistakes to find the
humor in the chaos of life and little
kids and laugh at those mistakes so if a
kid drops a cup of water on the ground
don't immediately scold and reprimand
and get angry laugh about it and
acknowledge that that was an accident
that kid didn't want to dump that cup
over
um and so again take your duties
seriously but not yourself that to me is
a key to well I don't know it'll make
life long and healthy but it will
certainly make it more enjoyable
I love that you ended on a mindset and a
philosophy because
you know one of the things that I wanted
to talk about was emotions and mindset
and where we are in those areas because
I think especially in the last couple of
years
we can all recognize that our emotions
and and and our thoughts are inseparable
from our well-being because we've seen
such
um you know a decline in mental health
which then spills into physical health
always so I'm glad that you I'm glad
that you ended like that thank you oh my
pleasure
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button